if there's one type of channel that I
enjoy more than BuzzFeed BuzzFeed close
I have found it right here the only
thing better than BuzzFeed BBC 3 pause
the online game hey guys let's grab a
bunch of people with a colorful
background that's popular right we can
do that too no no ah if you're not
familiar with BBC 3 the most popular
series they have is things not to say
too
basically it's things not to say to
people with disabilities which I think
it's a good idea because you generally
want to be respectful to these people
and a lot of times I'm like I don't know
I don't know what to say to you I had a
boy about same age as me turn to me and
say face and I looked him dead in the
eye and I said I've got a horrible
disease that you'll catch and so it
starts off by that which is you know a
good thing somewhere along their line
they ran out of ideas which BBC three if
you're watching I can relate okay I
understand
your suffering finally finally a video
of things that I'm tired of hearing as a
gamer all the time oh it's so hard being
a gamer people don't understand the
suffering maybe you can relate to this
as well let's watch it let's watch it
together you play video games but you
don't play proper video games cuz you're
a whamon Wehrman can't play video games
what are you oh I bet you play I bet you
play Sims [ __ ] love Sims am i right
oh I don't know what it is with girls
they want to prove to themselves so
badly that they're gamers but it's like
no one cares like no one cares
aren't you too old for that that is what
I hear all the time no I only just got
good girls can't get good at games this
has been scientifically proven because
they have whamon brains which is
inferior to male Prince I'm joking I'm
joking I'm joking
and it's scientific fact oh you may as
well say then again like TV shows are
for kids movies are for kids in other
words books and films are fulfilled in
casuals filthy casuals main oh hey the
4chan mean in real life what up what up
now games of the pros games fo epic
people like myself I'm an epic I'm and
why do I keep doing this
such a waste of money
oh whatever have you not heard of piracy
hey listen you can't steal what in your
copying I like her response
oh whatever I'm a well for anyway that
is not true it is a far more effective
way to spend your money no I can 100%
agree because like I've definitely
finished all of these games I've played
them from start to finish and I really
got my money's worth on all these all
these titles because I spent time
playing through all of them it's a
really really money money well spent if
you're into music you spend so much
money on an amp or a guitar or drum set
or something like that and it's just
like everyone's got a thing if you're a
gamer you have to buy a computer display
a keyboard like what what is your
argument here I don't understand this
statement is actually true
just like gaming encourages sexism which
has both been proven at many several
occasions can we move on with this
argument please one of the most annoying
things
we got ticked up they earn look how
angry you see just how furious they get
when they get this statement it's
because they are so extremely violent
violent thing completely but you know
what come on in start murdering
innocents if you are a violent person
you're a violent person and video games
are not gonna make you guys know violent
I only just met you but I know this
one's gonna wind you up did your
boyfriend get you into gaming I think
that's a yes no you just can't
I'm joking by the way it's a joke hey
sis I don't get why they get so ticked
off that's why it's funny to me okay
and provoking that's the joke okay calm
down
but Jesus cried on get it just like stop
caring and no one's gonna be all like
you belong oh you play oh you must be
really crap because she's a whamon and
whamon are inferior to video games I
play candy crush but I'm not a game now
that is not true that is a lie that is a
paradox you are a gamer what does that
tick people off are you serious
you are Pokemon guy but I'm not a gamer
like yeah you are really you can't
accept you a gamer
there was something wrong with you so
well I guess there's something wrong
with me well I guess there's something
wrong with me I don't understand I don't
understand why you have to define
yourself by the fact that you play video
games to me that's just [ __ ] pathetic
if you watch movies you wouldn't go I am
a MOLLE viewer I am am over yeah I'm
over what up I love movies have you seen
a short film your am over do you watch
YouTube you're a movie watching what the
[ __ ] do you mean can't you just play
candy crush without having to define
yourself as a [ __ ] gamer can I not
just play candy crush in my spare time
we're not big define us a goddamn game
what's the best thing about gaming oh
that question really oh I hate when
people ask me that question
nah it's almost when people ask me
what's wrong with my face oh how dare
they look at the smile of everything
quality quality content moving on
everybody as a whamon on the internet
it's it's tough it's tough out there
it's a tough it's a tough world to live
in you know I try to be on the forefront
of respecting whamon I am part of the
Ambassador Program respecting whamon org
slash respect people don't understand
what it's like so thank God for BBC
three because now we are going to learn
what it's like to be on the Internet
things you'll know it's your one
Facebook request I just sort of glanced
it and I just like switch off that never
happens to me never ever have I gotten a
random Facebook request and if you're a
male watching this as well I'm sure you
can agree with a random Facebook request
just doesn't happen to us males we are
so privileged and so lucky to be here
and just not having to get a bunch of
friend requests from people that you
don't know and you might think I will
put it your PewDiePie that's why you're
gonna get it I got them before okay I
got I've always gotten them it's because
I am half a man damn it
dick pics women get dick pics
who takes dick pics why would you take a
dick pic I don't understand the concept
of dick pic like you I wouldn't spread
my ass and take a picture of my butthole
even though it's a beautiful butthole by
the way it's absolutely beautiful
impeccable perfect symmetric but I
wouldn't take a picture of it yet alone
send it to someone seen I'm concerned
cuz I'm like Oh dick pic there's girls
like dick pic am I missing out on
something here cuz I thought girls
didn't like dick pics
mazi never think to myself you know I
could really do it tonight dick I
wouldn't really want a picture of
someone's vagina does that make me gay
hell no maybe a little bit
I don't know why I'm talking about this
but eat a coffee Q and then you're just
like bombarded with this like phallic
monstrosity on your phone that you just
don't want palek monstrosity I hate I
hate just being in line for coffee and
then you get bombarded with dick pics
and be like brat that you don't get a
dick pic and being like I'd really like
to have amazing consensual sex with you
do their phone become a dick like I
don't get it
finally a hot that gets it dating out
there is a lot of I think fetes ization
of like particularly women of color on
dating apps yes this is my perfect
opportunity you like to catch a black
woman I'm not a Pokemon are you KITT are
you serious I swear she was hitting on
me no wait now I'm just confused is that
the same as when you're walking down the
street and someone's like hey baby
to be fair yet no guys really have an
ego problem with rejection and I
understand this one is stop being so
[ __ ] pathetic
okay guys from the internet if she's not
interested that means you're ugly just
deal with it targeted advertising I
don't know where to start with this hey
it makes me angry to when I get targeted
ads towards myself if I get an ad for
for the latest video game I'm just I'm a
man I like James we'd get the
advertisement for like lose your belly
fat that's cuz you're fat and dude it
dude sorry you can't party shame I
forgot about that I forgot how about
this
maybe it's because you're fat vbc it's a
tax paid channel the BBC is run by the
government of UK if you have a TV
licence you're obligated to pay for it
now I don't have a TV licence it's the
first thing I [ __ ] unsigned up when I
moved to UK and they keep sending me
like are you sure are you sure about
this TV like let's like [ __ ] off no no
you will I would not support this [ __ ]
to be fair some of these videos I
thought we're good some of them flat-out
cancer but that pretty much sums up
BuzzFeed type of content anyway and my
content for that matter this has been
Peter pie remember to respect women and
leave a like for every like you respect
one women I'm sure there's going to be
some montage about although all the
women joke I made at some point in the
future but until then stay awesome for
us